fourteen-year-old boy just defeated a
Grandmaster with a brilliant Bishop
sacrifice a youngest player in the fide
World Cup adiz guerrell had a lot to
prove and that's exactly what he did
against Serbian GM vlimir ivich out of
the opening gorrell claimed to have been
in prep all the way until move 18 and in
this position he sacrificed the bishop
to find a brilliant checkmating threat
under immense pressure if each used 35
minutes before playing Bishop F5 which
was met with an immediate response by
gorrell the move was played in seconds
which with increment actually increased
guerrell's overall time with no way to
save the game evich resigned guerrell is
Within Reach of earning the coveted
Grand Master title the case was
certainly made after